The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're going
to continue our discussion
of methods of integration.
The method that I'm
going to describe today
handles a whole
class of functions
of the following form.
You take P(x) / Q(x) and this
is known as a rational function.
And all that means
is that it's a ratio
of two polynomials, which are
these functions P(x) and Q(x).
We'll handle all such
functions by a method which
is known as partial fractions.
And what this does is,
it splits P / Q into what
you could call easier pieces.
So that's going to be
some kind of algebra.
And that's what
we're going to spend
most of our time doing today.
I'll start with an example.
And all of my examples
will be illustrating
more general methods.
The example is to integrate the
function 1 1/(x-1) plus, say,
3/(x+2), dx.
That's easy to do.
It's just, we already
know the answer.
It's ln x - ln(x-1) + 3 ln(x+3).
Plus a constant.
So that's done.
So now, here's the difficulty
that is going to arise.
The difficulty is that I can
start with this function, which
is perfectly manageable.
And than I can add these
two functions together.
The way I add fractions.
So that's getting a
common denominator.
And so that gives me
x+2 here, plus 3(x-1).
And now if I combine
together all of these terms,
then altogether I have
4x + 2 - 3, that's -1.
And if I multiply out the
denominator that's x^2 plus--
That 2 turned into a
3, that's interesting.
I hope there aren't too many
more of those transformations.
Is there another one here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, it
happened earlier on.
Wow that's an interesting
vibration there.
OK.
Thank you.
So, I guess my 3's were
speaking to my 2's.
Somewhere in my past.
OK, anyway, I think
this is now correct.
So the problem is the following.
This is the problem with this.
This integral was easy.
I'm calling it easy, we
already know how to do it.
Over here.
But now over here,
it's disguised.
It's the same function,
but it's no longer clear
how to integrate it.
If you're faced
with this one, you
say, what am I supposed to do.
And we have to get
around that difficulty.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to unwind this disguise.
So we have the algebra
problem that we have.
Oh, wow.
There must be
something in the water.
Impressive.
Wow.
OK, let's see.
Is 2/3 = 3/2?
Holy cow.
Well that's good.
Well, I'll keep you awake
today with several other
transpositions here.
So our algebra problem is to
detect the easy pieces which
are inside.
And the method that
we're going to use,
the one that we'll
emphasize anyway,
is one algebraic trick
which is a shortcut, which
is called the cover-up method.
But we're going to talk about
even more general things
than that.
But anyway, this is
where we're headed.
Is something called
the cover-up method.
Alright.
So that's our intro.
And I'll just have to
remember that 2 is not 3.
I'll keep on repeating that.
So now here I'm going
to describe to you
how we unwind this disguise.
The first step is, we
write down the function
we want to integrate.
Which was this.
And now we have to undo the
first damage that we did.
So the first step is to
factor the denominator.
And that factors, we
happen to know the factors,
so I'm not going
to carry this out.
But this can be a
rather difficult step.
But we're going to
assume that it's done.
For the purposes of
illustration here.
So I factor the denominator.
And now, the second thing
that I'm going to do
is what I'm going to
call the setup here.
How I'm going to set things up.
And I'll tell you what
these things are more
systematically in a second.
And the setup is that I
want to somehow detect
what I did before.
And I'm going to write
some unknowns here.
What I expect is that this
will break up into two pieces.
One with the
denominator x - 1, and
the other with the
denominator x + 2.
So now, my third step is going
to be to solve for A and B.
And then I'm done, if I do that.
That's the complete
unwinding of this disguise.
And this is where the cover-up
method comes in handy.
This is this method that
I'm about to describe.
Now, you can do the
algebra in a clumsy way,
or you can do it in a quick way.
And we'd like to get efficient
about the algebra involved.
And so let me show you what
the first step in the trick is.
We're going to solve for A
by multiplying by (x - 1).
Now, notice if you multiply
by (x - 1) in that equation 2,
what you get is this.
You got (4x - 2) divided
by-- The (x-1)'s cancel.
You get this on
the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand
side you get A.
The (x-1)'s cancel again.
And then we get this extra term.
Which is B x+2 times x-1.
Now, the trick here, and we're
going to get even better trick
in just a second.
The trick here is that
I didn't try to clear
the denominators completely.
I was very efficient
about the way I did it.
It just cleared one factor.
And the result here
is very useful.
Namely, if I plug in now x =
1, this term drops out too.
So what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to plug in x = 1.
And what I get on the left-hand
side here is 4 - 1 and 1 + 2,
and on the left-hand side
I get A. That's the end.
This is my formula for A.
A happens to be equal to 1.
And that's, of
course, what I expect.
A had better be 1, because the
thing broke up into 1/(x-1) +
3/(x+2).
So this is the correct answer.
There was a question out
here, which I missed.
STUDENT: Aren't
polynomials defined
as functions with whole powers,
or could they be square roots?
PROFESSOR: Are
polynomials defined
as functions with whole powers,
or can they be square roots?
That's the question.
The answer is, they
only have whole powers.
So for instance here I only
have the power 1 and 0.
Here I have the powers 2,
1 and 0 in the denominator.
Square roots are no
good for this method.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why did I say x = 1?
The reason why I said x = 1
was that it works really fast.
You can't know this in advance,
that's part of the method.
It just turns out to be
the best thing to do.
The fastest way of getting
at the coefficient A. Now
the curious thing, let me
just pause for a second
before I do it.
If I had plugged x = 1
into the original equation,
I would have gotten nonsense.
Because I would've gotten
0 in the denominator.
And that seems like the
most horrible thing to do.
The worst possible thing
to do, is to set x = 1.
On the other hand,
what we did is a trick.
We multiplied by x - 1.
And that turned the
equation into this.
So now, in disguise,
I multiplied by 0.
But that turns out
to be legitimate.
Because really this equation
is true for all x except 1.
And then instead
of taking x = 1,
I can really take x tends to 1.
That's really what I need.
The limit as x goes to one.
The equation is
still valid then.
So I'm using the worst
case, the case that
looks like it's dividing by 0.
And it's helping me because
it's cancelling out all
the information in terms of B.
So the advantage here is this
cancellation that
occurs in this part.
So that's the method.
We're going to shorten it
much, much more in a second.
But let me carry it out for
the other coefficient as well.
So the other coefficient
I'm going to solve for B,
I'm going to multiply by x + 2.
And when I do that,
I get (4x-1)/(x-1),
that's the left-hand side,
the very top expression there.
And then down below I
get A/(x-1) ( (x+2).
And then again the
(x+2)'s cancel.
So I get B sitting alone.
And now I'm going to
do the same trick.
I'm going to set x = -2.
That's the value which is going
to knock out this A term here.
So that cancels this
term completely.
And what we get here all told
is - 8 - (-8 - 1)/(-2 - 1) = B.
In other words, B = 3, which
was also what it was supposed
to be.
B was this number 3, right here.
Which I'm now not
going to change to 2.
Because I know that it's not 2.
There was a question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Now, this is the method
which is called cover-up.
But it's really carried out
much, much faster than this.
So I'm going to
review the method
and I'm going to show you
what it is in general.
So the first step is to factor
the denominator, Q. That's
what I labeled 1 over there.
That was the factorization
of the denominator up top.
The second step is what I'm
going to call the setup.
That's step 2.
And that's where I knew what
I was aiming for in advance.
And I'm going to have
to explain to you
in every instance exactly
what this setup should be.
That is, what the unknowns
should be and what target,
simplified expression,
we're aiming for.
So that's the setup.
And then the third step is
what I'll now call cover-up.
Which is just a very
fast way of doing
what I did on this last
board, which is solving
for the unknown coefficients.
So now, let me perform
it for you again.
Over here.
So it's 4x - 1 divided by-- So
this is to eliminate writing
here.
Handwriting.
It makes it much faster.
So this part just
factoring the denominator,
that was 1, that was step 1.
And then step 2, again,
is the setup, which
is setting it up like this.
Alright, that's the setup.
And now I claim that
without writing very much,
I can figure out
what A and B are.
Just by staring at this.
So now what I'm going
to do is I'm just going
to think what I did over there.
And I'm just going
to do it directly.
So let me show you what the
method consists of visually.
I'm going to cover up, that
is, knock out this factor,
and focus on this number here.
And I'm going to plug
in the thing that
makes this 0, which is x = 1.
So I'm plugging in x = 1.
To this left-hand side.
And what I get is (4
- 1)/(1 + 2) = A. Now,
that's the same thing
I did over there.
I just did it by skipping the
intermediate algebra step,
which is a lot of writing.
So the cover-up method really
amounts to the following thing.
I'm thinking of
multiplying this over here.
It cancels this and it gets
rid of everything else.
And it just leaves me with
A on the right-hand side.
And I have to get rid
of it on this side.
So in other words,
by eliminating this,
I'm isolating a on
the right-hand side.
So the cover-up is that I'm
covering this and getting
A out of it.
Similarly, I can
do the same thing
with B. It's focused
on the value x = -2.
And B is what I'm getting
on the right-hand side.
And then I have
to cover up this.
So if I cover up that, then
what's left over, with x = -2,
is again (-8 - 1)/(-2 - 1).
So this is the way the method
gets carried out in practice.
Writing, essentially,
the least you can.
Now, when you get to
several variables,
it becomes just way more
convenient to do this.
So now, let me just review
when cover-up works.
So this cover-up
method works if Q(x)
has distinct linear factors.
And, so you need
two things here.
It has to factor
completely, the denominator
has to factor completely.
And the degree of
the numerator has
to be strictly less than the
degree of the denominator.
I'm going to give
you an example here.
So, for instance-- And this
tells you the general pattern
of the setup also.
Say you had x^2 +
3x + 8, let's say.
Over (x - 1) (x - 2) (x + 5).
So here I'm going to
tell you the setup.
The setup is going to be -
A/(x-1) + B/(x-2) + C/(x+5).
And it will always
break up into something.
So however many
factors you have,
you'll have to put in a
term for each of those.
And then you can
find each number here
by this cover-up method.
Now we're done with that.
And now we have to go on to
the algebraic complications.
So would the first typical
algebraic complication be.
It would be repeated
roots or repeated factors.
Let me get one that doesn't come
out to be extremely ugly here.
So this is what
we'll call Example 2.
And this is going to
work when the degree,
you always need that the
degree of the numerator
is less than the degree
of the denominator.
And Q has now repeated
linear factors.
So let's see which example
I wanted to show you.
So let's just give this here.
I'll just repeat
the denominator.
With an extra factor like this.
Now, the main thing
you need to know,
since I've already performed
the factorization for you.
Already performed Step 1.
This is Step 1 here.
You have to factor
things all the way,
and that's already
been done for you.
And here's what this setup is.
The setup is that it's of the
form A/(x-1) plus B/(x-1)^2 -
we need another term for the
square here - plus C/(x+2).
In general, if you
have more powers
you just need to keep on
putting in those powers.
You need one for
each of the powers.
Why does it have to be squared?
OK.
Good question.
So why in the world
am I doing this?
Let me just give you one hint
as to why I'm doing this.
It's very, very much like the
decimal expansion of a number
or, say, the base 2
expansion of a number.
So, for, example the number 7/16
is 0/2 + 1/2^2 + 1/2^3 plus,
is that right?
So it's 4/16 + 1/2^4.
It's this sort of thing.
And I'm getting this
power and this power.
If I have higher
powers, I'm going
to have to have more and more.
So this is what happens
when I have a 2^4.
I have to represent
things like this.
That's what's coming out of
this piece with the repetitious
here.
Of the powers.
This is just an analogy.
Of what we're doing.
Yeah, another
question over here.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this is an example,
but it's meant
to represent the general
case and I will also
give you a general picture.
For sure, once you have
the second power here,
you'll need both the
first and the second power
mentioned over here.
And since there's only
a first power over here
I only have to mention a
first power over there.
If this were a 3 here, there
would be one more term which
would be the one for
(x-1)^3 in the denominator.
That's what you just said.
OK, now, what's different
about this setup
is that the cover-up
method, although it works,
it doesn't work so well.
It doesn't work quite as well.
The cover-up works for
the coefficients B and C,
not A. We'll have a quick
method for the numbers B and C.
To figure out what they are.
But it will be a
little slower to get
to A, which we will do last.
Let me show you how it works.
First of all, I'm going to do
the ordinary cover-up with C.
So for C, I just want
to do the same old thing
that I did before.
I cover up this,
and that's going
to get rid of all the junk
except for the C term.
So I have to plug in x = -2.
And I get x-- sorry, I get
(-2)^2 + 2 in the numerator.
And I get (-2 - 1)^2
in the denominator.
Remember I'm covering this up.
So that's all there is
on the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand
side all there is C.
Everything else got killed
off, because it was x -
2 times that.
That's 0 times all
that other stuff.
And the x - 2 over
here canceled.
This is the shortcut
that I just described,
and this is much faster than
doing all that arithmetic.
And algebra.
So all together this
is a 6/9, right?
So it's C = 6/9, which is 2/3.
Now, the other one
which is easy to do,
I'm going to do by
the slow method first.
But you omit a term.
The idea is to cover up
the other bad factor.
Cover-ups, I'll do it both
the fast way and the slow way.
I'll do it the fast way
first, and then I'll
show you the slow way.
The fast way is
to cover this up.
And then I have to cover
up everything else.
That gets eliminated.
And that includes everything
but B. So I get B on this side.
And I get 1 on that side.
So that's (1^2 + 2) / (1 + 2).
So in other words, B = 1.
That was pretty fast, so let
me show you what arithmetic
was hiding behind that.
What algebra was
hiding behind it.
What I was really doing is this.
And multiplying through
by (x-1)^2, so I got this.
So this canceled here, so
this C just stands alone.
And then I have here
C/(x+2) (x-1)^2.
Notice again, I
cleared out that one--
this term from the
denominator and sent it over
to the other side.
Now, what's happening
is that when I set x = 1
here, this term is dying.
This term is going
away, because there's
more powers in the numerator
than in the denominator.
This is still 0.
And this one is gone also.
So all that's left is B. Now,
I cannot pull that off with
a single power of x - 1.
I can't expose the A term.
It's the B term
that I can expose.
Because I can multiply
through by this thing squared.
If I multiply through
by just x - 1,
what'll happen here is I won't
have canceled this (x-1)^2.
It's useless.
I still have a 0
in the denominator.
I'll have B / 0 when
I plug in x = 1.
Which I can't use.
Again, the cover-up method
is giving us B and C, not A.
Now, for the last
term, for A, I'm
going to just have to be
straightforward about it.
And so I'll just suggest for A,
plug in your favorite number.
So plug in my favorite number.
Which is x = 0.
And you won't be
able to plug in x = 0
if you've already used it.
Here the two numbers we've
already used are x = 1
and x = -2.
But we haven't used x =
0 yet, so that's good.
I'm going to plug in now
x = 0 into the equation.
What do I get?
I get 0 (0^2 + 2) / ((-1)^2
* 2) is equal to, let's see.
A is the thing
that I don't know.
So it's A A/(-1) + B/(x-1)^2,
so B = 1, so that's 1 1/(-1)^2.
And then C was 2/3.
2/3 / (x+2).
So that's 0 + 2.
Don't give up at this point.
This is a lot of algebra.
You really have to plug
in all these numbers.
You make one arithmetic
mistake and you're always
going to get the wrong answer.
This is very
arithmetically intensive.
However, it does
simplify at this point.
We have 2/2, that's 1.
Is equal to -A + 1 + 1/3.
So let's see.
A on the other side,
this becomes A = 1/3.
And that's it.
This is the end.
We've we've simplified
our function.
And now it's easy to integrate.
Question.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
if x = 0 has already been used,
what do I do?
And the answer is,
pick something else.
And you said pick
a random number.
And that's right, except
that if you really
picked a random number
it would be 4.12567843,
which would be difficult.
What you want to pick
is the easiest possible
number you can think of.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If you had, as in
this sort of situation here,
more powers.
Wouldn't you have
more variables.
Very good question.
That's absolutely right.
This was a 3 by 3
system in disguise,
for these three
unknowns, A, B and C.
What we started with in
the previous problem was
two variables.
It's over here, the
variables A and B.
And as the degree of
the denominator goes up,
the number of variables goes up.
It gets more and more
and more complicated.
More and more
arithmetically intensive.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, so.
The question is, how
would you solve it
if you have two unknowns.
That's exactly the point here.
This is a system of simultaneous
equations for unknowns.
And we have little tricks for
isolating single variables.
Otherwise we're stuck with
solving the whole system.
And you'd have to solve the
whole system by elimination,
various other tricks.
I'll say a little
more about that later.
Now, I have to get one
step more complicated
with my next example.
My next example is going
to have a quadratic factor.
So still I'm sticking to
the degree of the polynomial
and the numerator is less than
in the denominator.
And I'm going to take the case
where Q has a quadratic factor.
Let me just again
illustrate this by example.
I have here (x - 1) (x^2 + 1).
I'll make it about
as easy as they come.
Now, the setup will be
slightly different here.
Here's the setup.
It's already factored.
I've already done
as much as I can do.
I can't factor this x^2 + 1 into
linear factors unless you know
about complex numbers.
If you know about
complex numbers
this method becomes much easier.
And it comes back to
the cover-up method.
Which is the way that the
cover-up method was originally
conceived by Heaviside.
But you won't get
to that until 18.03.
So we'll wait.
This, by the way, is a method
which is used for integration.
But it was invented
to do something
with Laplace transforms
and inversion
of certain kinds of
differential equations.
By Heaviside.
And so it came much
later than integration.
But anyway, it's a
very convenient method.
So here's the setup
with this one.
Again, we want a term
for this (x - 1) factor.
And now we're going to also have
a term with the denominator x^2
+ 1.
But this is the difference.
It's now going to be a
first degree polynomial.
One degree down from
the quadratic here.
So this is what I keep
on calling the setup,
this is number 2.
You have to know that in
advance based on the pattern
that you see on
the left-hand side.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is, if
the degree of the numerator--
So in this case,
if this were cubed,
and this is matching with
the denominator, which
is total of degree 3.
The answer is that
this does not work.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It
definitely doesn't work.
And we're going to have to do
something totally different
to handle it.
Which turns out, fortunately,
to be much easier than this.
But we'll deal with
that at the end.
Keep this in mind.
This is an easy way to
make a mistake if you start
with a higher degree numerator.
You'll never get
the right answer.
So now, so I have my setup now.
And now what can I do?
Well, I claim that I
can still do cover-up
for A. It's the same idea.
I cover this guy up.
And if I really multiply by it
it would knock everything out
but A. So I cover this
up and I plug in x = 1.
So I get here 1^2 / (1^2 +1)
= A. In other words, A = 1/2.
Again cover-up is pretty
fast, as you can see.
It's not too bad.
Now, at this next stage,
I want to find B and C.
And the best idea
is the slow way.
Here, it's not too terrible.
But it's just what
we're going to do.
Which is to clear the
denominators completely.
So for B and C, just
clear the denominator.
That means multiply through
by that whole business.
Now, when you do that on the
left-hand side you're going
to get x^2.
Because I got rid of
the whole denominator.
On the right-hand side when
I bring this up, the x -
1 will cancel with this.
So the A term will
be A(x^2 + 1).
And the Bx + C term will have
a remaining factor of x - 1.
Because the x^2 + 1 will cancel.
Again, the arithmetic
here is not too terrible.
Now I'm going to
do the following.
I'm going to look
at the x^2 term.
On the left-hand side
and the right-hand side.
And that will give me
one equation for B and C.
And then I'm going to do the
same thing with another term.
The x^2 term on the left-hand
side, the coefficient is 1.
It's 1 times x^2.
On the other side, it's A.
Remember I actually have A.
So I'm going to put
it in, it's 1/2.
So this is the A term.
And so I get 1/2 x^2.
And then the only other x^2 is
when this Bx multiplies this x.
So Bx * x is Bx^2, so this is--
the other coefficient on x^2 is
B. And that forces B to be 1/2.
And last of all, I'm
going to do the x^0 term.
Or, otherwise known
as the constant term.
And on the left-hand side,
the constant term is 0.
There is no constant term.
On the right-hand side there's
a constant term, 1/2 * 1.
That's 1/2 here.
And then there's
another constant term,
which is this constant
times this -1 Which is -C.
And so the conclusion
here is that C = 1/2.
Another question.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There's also
an x^0 hidden in here.
Sorry, an x^1, that's what
you were asking about, sorry.
There's also an x^1.
The only reason why I didn't go
to the x^1 is that it turns out
with these two I didn't need it.
The other thing is
that by experience, I
know that the extreme
ends of the multiplication
are the easiest ends.
And the middle terms
have tons of cross terms.
And so I don't like the middle
term as much because it always
involves more arithmetic.
So I stick to the lowest and
the highest terms if I can.
So that was really
a sneaky thing.
I did that without
saying anything.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Another
good question.
Could I just set x equals 0?
Absolutely.
In fact, that's equivalent
to picking out the x^0 term.
And you could plug in numbers.
If you wanted.
That's another way of doing
this besides doing that.
So you can also plug in numbers.
Can plug in numbers. x = 0.
Actually, not x = 1, right?
-1, 2, etc.
Not 1 just because
we've already used it.
We won't get interesting
information out.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, could I
have done it this other way.
With the polynomial,
with this other one.
Yes, absolutely.
So in other words
what I've taught
you now is two choices which
are equally reasonable.
The one that I
picked was the one
that was the fastest
for this guy and the one
that was fastest for
this one, but I could've
done the other way around.
There are a lot of ways of
solving simultaneous equations.
Yeah, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is the following.
So now everybody can
understand the question.
If this, instead of being
x^2 + 1, this were x^3 + 1.
So that's an important
case to understand.
That's a case in which
this denominator is not
fully factored.
So it's an x^3 + 1, you would
have to factor out an x + 1.
So that would be a situation
like this, you have an x^3 + 1,
but that's (x+1) (x^2 +x
+ 1), this kind of thing.
If that's the right, there must
be a minus sign in here maybe.
OK, something like this.
Right?
Isn't that what it is?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think it's right.
But anyway, the point is
that you have to factor it.
And then you have a
linear and a quadratic.
So you're always going
to be faced eventually
with linear factors
and quadratic factors.
If you have a cubic, that
means you haven't factored
sufficiently.
So you're still back in Step 1.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: In the x^3 + 1 case?
PROFESSOR: In the x^3 + 1
case, we are out of luck until
we've completed
the factorization.
Once we've completed
the factorization,
we're going to have to
deal with these two factors
as denominators.
So it'll be this plus
something over x + 1
plus a Bx + C type of
thing over this thing here.
That's what's eventually
going to happen.
But hold on to that idea.
Let me carry out one
more example here.
So I've figured out
what all the values are.
But I think it's also
worth it to remember now
that we also have to
carry out the integration.
What I've just shown you is that
the integral of x^2 dx over (x
- 1)(x^2 + 1) is equal to,
and I've split up into these
pieces.
So what are the pieces?
The pieces are, 1/2, x -
1, plus 1/2 x / (x^2 + 1).
This is the A term.
This is the B term.
And then there's the C term.
So we'd better remember that we
know how to antidifferentiate
these things.
In other words, I want
to finish the problem.
The others were
pretty easy, so I
didn't bother to
finish my sentence,
but here I want to
be careful and have
you realize that there's
something a little more to do.
First of all we have the,
the first one is no problem.
That's this.
The second one actually
is not too bad either.
This is, by the advanced
guessing method,
my favorite method,
something like the logarithm,
because that's what's going
to appear in the denominator.
And then, if you
differentiate this,
you're going to
get 2x over this.
But here we have 1/2.
So altogether it's 1/4 of this.
So I fixed the coefficient here.
And then the last one,
you have to think back
to some level of memorization
here and remember that this
is 1/2 the arc tangent.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why did I go to 1/4?
Because in disguise,
for this guy,
I was thinking d/dx of ln(x^2
+ 1) is 2x / (x^2 + 1).
Because it's the derivative
of this divided by itself.
This is-- The derivative
of ln u is u' / u.
(ln u)' = u' / u.
That was what I applied.
And what I had was 1/2, so I
need a total of 1/4 to cancel.
So 2/4 is 1/2.
Now I've got to get you
out of one more deep hole.
And I'm going to save the
general pattern for next time.
But I do want to
clarify one thing.
So let's handle this thing.
What if the degree
of P is bigger than
or equal to the degree of Q.
That's the thing that I claimed
was easier.
And I'm going to describe
to you how it's done.
Now, in analogy,
with numbers you
might call this an
improper fraction.
That's the thing that
should echo in your mind
when you're thinking about this.
And I'm just going to
do it by example here.
Let's see., I
cooked up an example
so that I don't
make an arithmetic
mistake along the way.
So there are two or three
steps that I need to explain.
So here's an example.
The denominator's degree 2,
the numerator is degree 3.
It well exceeds, so
there's a problem here.
Our method is not going to work.
And the first step that
I want to carry out
is to reverse Step 1.
That is, I don't want
the factorization
for what I'm going to do next.
I want it multiplied out.
That means I have to multiply
through, so I get x^2 + x - 2.
I'm back to the
starting place here.
And now, the next thing
that I'm going to do
is, I'm going to
use long division.
That's how you convert
an improper fraction
to a proper fraction.
This is something
you were supposed
to learn in, I don't
know, Grade 4, I know.
Grade 3, Grade 4,
Grade 5, Grade 6, etc.
So here's how it works in
the case of polynomials.
It's kind of amusing.
So we're dividing this
polynomial into that one.
And so the quotient to
first order here is x.
That is, that's going
to match the top terms.
So I get x^3 + x^2 - 2x.
That's the product.
And now I subtract.
And it cancels.
So we get here -x^2 + 2x.
That's the difference.
And now I need to divide
this next term in.
And I need a -1.
So -1 times this
is -x^2 - x + 2.
And I subtract.
And the x^2's cancel.
And here I get +3x - 2.
Now, this thing has a name.
This is called the quotient.
And this thing also has a name.
This is called the remainder.
And now I'll show you how
it works by sticking it
into the answer here.
The quotient is x - 1.
And the remainder is,
let's get down there.
(3x - 2) / (x^2 + x - 2).
So the punchline here
is that this thing
is easy to integrate.
This is easy.
And this one, you
can use, now you
can use cover-up, The
method that we had before.
Because the degree
of the numerator
is now below the degree
of the denominator.
It's now first degree and
this is second degree.
What you can't do
is use cover-up
to start out with here.
That will give you
the wrong answer.
So that's the end for today,
and see you next time.